Jetzt ist es bald soweit. Am Freitag startet die Europameisterschaft 2024. Da gibt es viel Sportliches zuzusagen, aber ja auch viel zur Organisation, zu diesem Turnier und auch zu den Kosten dieses Turniers. Und weil dazu mehrere gute Recherchen erschienen sind, unter anderem im Deutschlandfunk und vom Korrektiv, habe ich jetzt zwei Gäste hier. Genau vom Deutschlandfunk, Matthias Friebe und vom Korrektiv, Stella Hesch. Und jetzt hier im Rasenfunk, los geht's. Ein bisschen lahmbarer dieser Applaus damals bei der Verkündung, dass Deutschland die EM bekommt, aber es wird eben nicht ganz so hochgepresst wie bei FIFA-WMs. Das muss man dann doch sagen und damit Hallo und herzlich willkommen hier im Rasenfunk. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost und ich freue mich sehr, dass Matthias Friebe hier ist, der diesen Ton auch schon öfter gehört hat. Denn ich glaube, ich habe ihn sogar in deinem Stück da was gehört. Hallo Matthias. Also gerade noch, dass sie ein bisschen geklatscht und sich umarmt haben, oder?
Ja, das war so ein bisschen eine sterile Atmosphäre. So ungefähr da, wo immer die Auslosungen für Champions-League-Spiele sonst waren. Und irgendwie war die Freude jetzt nicht so überbordend, hatte man das Gefühl.
Ja gut, ich meine, die Delegationen wissen sie ja auch schon, bevor der Umschlag aufgemacht wird. Das kommt da wahrscheinlich noch mit dazu. Vielleicht, aber haben sie ja auch schon geahnt, Mensch, jetzt kommt viel Arbeit auf uns zu. Zu viel Arbeit hatte auch Stella Hesch vom gemeinwohlorientierten Medienhaus Korrektiv Friends of the Rasenfunk. Möchte ich fast schon sagen, denn ihr finanziert euch ganz ähnlich, wie wir. Stella, schön, dass du mal hier bist. Danke. Und wie ist bei dir die Vorfreude auf dieses Turnier? Du hast jetzt viel arbeiten dürfen rund um das Turnier, deswegen bist du ja auch hier. Dein Hype-Level so ungefähr?
Ähm, niedrig. Ich kann tatsächlich sagen, ich bin niemand, der Sport einschaltet. Wenn ihr mich erwischt beim Fußballgucken, dann passiert das eher zufällig, weil es gerade irgendwo im Restaurant in der Kneipe läuft. Aber ich nehme darauf für mich persönlich nicht viel mit.
Aber wird das jetzt auch zur EM so sein?
Ja, tatsächlich. Also das ist ganz egal, ob EM, WM. Da bin ich raus, ich persönlich.
Das ist ja, das finde ich richtig fast, ehrlich gesagt, da würde ich fast am liebsten jetzt eine Sendung drüber machen. Was macht man dann während eines Fußballturniers? Das heißt, du gehst dann ins Schwimmbad, weil da keiner ist, du gehst ins Kino, weil da keiner ist oder was machst du dann?
Ich habe ja das Glück, Berlin ist groß. Ich glaube, das verläuft sich ganz gut. Würde ich noch in Dortmund wohnen, wie vor einem dreiviertel Jahr, wäre das vielleicht was anderes. Vielleicht würde ich da gar nicht so drum rumkommen. Aber ich glaube, es gibt in Berlin einige Menschen, die das genauso sehen wie ich.
Also irgendwie, das wäre doch auch mal eine schöne Reportage für dich, Matthias. Was machen eigentlich die Menschen, die nicht gerade die Spiele verfolgen? Kannst du dich mal an Stellas Fersen heften, würde ich vorschlagen. Für dich ist es wahrscheinlich jetzt eher Vorausblick auf viel Arbeit, die kommt, gemischt mit, weiß nicht, ist da Vorfreude dabei?
Ja, schon Vorfreude dabei, weil es natürlich eine besondere Zeit irgendwie ist, die ja, glaubt, kann man schon sagen, irgendwie auch so ein bisschen Ausnahmezustand ist in der Redaktion und auch in meinem Reportersein. Ich darf jetzt zum fünften Mal insgesamt bei so einem großen Turnier als Reporter für unsere drei Programme unterwegs sein und versuche, möglichst viele Eindrücke in vielen Städten zu gewinnen. Ganz andere Setting, diesmal zu Hause und nicht in Russland oder in Katar. Und ich freue mich schon drauf, weil ich glaube, wir werden viele spannende Geschichten erzählen können.
Das glaube ich. Wie wirst du reisen, Matthias? Würdest du die Bahn verwenden?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich gerade eins der Hauptthemen. Ich bin verabredet am Tag vor dem Eröffnungsspiel zu einem Interview in München, und überlege mir gerade, wie viel Puffer ich einkalkulieren muss, um dieses Interview nicht zu gefährden. Und bin inzwischen bei drei Stunden angekommen in meiner eigentlichen Planung. Mehr geht auch nicht, weil vorher fährt noch nichts an dem Tag. Mal gucken. Also ich werde es mit der Bahn probieren.
Also da werden auf jeden Fall Geschichten liegen. Das kann ich dir sagen, Matthias. Da wirst du einen reichen Fundus dran haben. Ich habe mich jetzt tatsächlich dagegen entschieden. Ich habe gestern alle Planungen gemacht und habe gesehen, wenn ich zum Teil nur einen Zug habe, der quasi Ersatz ist für einen, der ausfällt, dann ist es meiner Erfahrung nach zu wenig. Deswegen werde ich jetzt tatsächlich leider viel mehr im Auto fahren müssen und dann gar nicht die vielen Fans treffen in den Zügen und so weiter. Da hätte ich total Lust drauf gehabt. Aber tja, naja, also das wird ein eigenes Thema. Selbst Niklas Föhlkruck hat Respekt vor der Bahn, wie er es gesagt hat, auf der DFB Pressekonferenz und ist deswegen mit einem Abi-Jahrgang angereist. Sehr schöne Nebengeschichten, die dieses Turnier schreibt. Aber wir wollen es natürlich mit den Hauptgeschichten befassen. Und heute soll das Thema das Drumherum sein, auch das finanzielle Drumherum dieser Europameisterschaft. Denn all der Aufwand, der betrieben wird in den zehn Spielorten für diese Spiele, der kostet einiges, der bringt auch sehr viel Geld ein. Allerdings gibt es da ein Ungleichgewicht in dem, was gegeben und was genommen wird. Und darüber wollen wir heute sprechen. Und Matthias, weil du ein sehr schönes Stück gemacht hast im Deutschlandfunk, das werde ich auch noch mal verlinken, wo du vorausgeblickt hast auf die Rahmenbedingungen dieser EM. Lass uns doch mal mit der Antwort auf die Frage beginnen, wie wird uns denn diese EM eigentlich von Uefa und vom DFB verkauft?
Naja, als das größte Ding, was man so haben kann, abseits von Olympischen Spielen, die wir auch noch haben in diesem Sommer, und Fußballweltmeisterschaften als das drittgrößte Sportereignis der Welt, als die absolute große Megabühne. Ich glaube, das ist auch tatsächlich so, was globale Aufmerksamkeit angeht. Sind die Einschaltquoten ja auf allen Kontinenten eigentlich spürbar? Aber naja, klar, bei allem, was da durchschimmert ist, wir wollen da viel Geld mitverdienen, da kann man mit viel Geld verdienen. Also die Uefa hat sich ja schon im Januar hingestellt und gesagt, so, wir sind ausverkauft, Sponsoren sind weg, Fernsehrechte sind weg. Für uns ist die EM noch sechs Monate weg, aber wir haben schon gewonnen und es ist ein Erfolg, und wir werden so und so viel Geld einstreichen. Ich glaube, der Umsatz wird bei 2,4 Milliarden liegen, so viel wie nie zuvor. Und damit gehen sie auch offen um. Dann ist die EM ein Erfolg, so sagen sie es ganz wörtlich sogar.
Wobei ich ja, ich habe Verbindungen zu Menschen, die mit diesen Sponsoring-Tickets zu tun haben. Verkauft waren da noch nicht alle, aber für die Uefa war es wahrscheinlich schon als verkauft verbucht. Das zeigt ja die enormen Summen, die da bewegt werden. Stella, ich nehme an, dass das auch einer der Gründe war, warum das für euch vom Korrektiv her interessant war, darüber zu berichten. Eben diese enormen Kosten, aber auch Gewinne, die es gibt im Fußball mit der EM.
Ja, also Gewinne ja erstmal vor allem für die Uefa. Was die Städte da tatsächlich zurückbekommen am Ende, das ist ja gar nicht so klar. Beziehungsweise auch einfach nicht kalkulierbar, auch wenn da immer von großen Summen die Rede ist. Aber wie belastbar die Berechnungen sind, das ist dann wieder die andere Frage. Und ja, wir wollten eben schauen, was geben die Städte aus, beziehungsweise womit war vielleicht auch mal 2017 in der Bewerbungsphase geplant. Und ja, wissen die Städte eigentlich, worauf sie sich einlassen, wenn sie diesen ganzen Bedingungen und Anforderungen der Uefa zustimmen.
Und interessant ist ja auch hier nochmal der Rückschluss auf das Jahr 2017, in dem eben die Bewerbungsphase lief. Und da ist es wichtig, sich zu erinnern, Matthias. Es gab damals einen sehr guten Mitbewerber, die Türkei, die ist aus ganz vielen Gründen sicherlich auch, also hatte sehr gute Argumente, dass auch dort das Turnier hätte stattfinden können. Und Recep Tayyip Erdogan, der hat sich auch voll in die Bresche geworfen. Der hat gesagt, ihr könnt hier mietfrei unsere Stadien verwenden. Ihr müsst natürlich keinerlei Steuern zahlen. Ich denke, das muss man mitbedenken, wenn wir jetzt dann auch gleich drüber sprechen, welche Zugeständnisse Deutschland machen musste. Das ist aber, so wie ich es jetzt wahrgenommen habe, auf keiner Pressekonferenz mehr Thema gewesen. Du warst ja auch auf vielen, hast ja auch jetzt berichtet über, wie eben der DFB auf dieses Turnier vorausblickt. Da will man nicht so gerne drüber sprechen oder es werden gar nicht die Fragen danach gestellt? Woran liegt das?
Ja, das ist glaube ich nicht so im ersten Interesse, diese Fragen zu stellen. Also Stella und eure Recherchen, die sind natürlich wichtig und die interessieren auch, glaube ich, einen großen Kreis. Aber so die ganz große Masse wird natürlich dann doch eher von den Themen fasziniert, die wir in anderen Formaten, auch hier im Rasenfunk, sicherlich besprechen. Da geht es ja dann darum, wie ist die deutsche Mannschaft drauf und hat Gündow an die richtige Position oder welche Fragen man sich sonst stellen sollte. Das ist was, diese Steuerfreiheit, da redet ja auch die Politik nicht gerne drüber. Ich glaube, nicht mal die Ministerien untereinander haben alle Informationen ausgetauscht. Also das Finanzministerium sagt ja, wir haben Steuergeheimnisse in Deutschland und mehr sagen wir dazu nicht. Ihr könnt euch auf den Kopf stellen, könnt ihr jetzt gerne gegen klagen, der Weg steht euch frei, aber wir sagen nichts dazu. Inzwischen wissen wir ja, dass der damalige Finanzminister Olaf Scholz selber unterschrieben hat, dass es diese Steuerfreiheit gibt. Die Uefa, diese Konstruktion des Turniers ist ja ein bisschen besonders. Also wir haben ja die Uefa als den Ausrichter der Europameisterschaft, die sitzt in der Schweiz und wir haben den DFB als Gastgebendenverband und die zusammen haben einen Joint Venture gegründet, die Euro24 GmbH, die sitzt in Frankfurt und die sind sozusagen für den ganzen organisatorischen Ablauf zuständig, für alles das, was konkret gemacht wird, für Vereinbarungen mit der Bahn, all diese Dinge mit den Host Cities zum Beispiel. Und die sind natürlich steuerpflichtig, da kann auch niemand was dran ändern. Die haben schon gesagt, sie werden rund 65 Millionen Euro Steuern zahlen. Aber da geht es natürlich nur um das, was durch diese GmbH durchgeschleift wird. Alle großen Verträge, alle großen Sponsoring-Abschlüsse bis hin zum Beer-Partner der Europameisterschaft, alle Fernsehverträge, wo ja das richtige Geld bis hin zu zwei Milliarden gemacht werden, werden natürlich direkt mit der Uefa in der Schweiz abgeschlossen. Und da kommt man natürlich ganz gut drum rum, hier um Steuern zu bezahlen. Und da wird ein Großteil des Umsatzes eben anderweitig verbucht.
Und gleichzeitig ist es so, dass ja auch die Spielorte, die müssen ja auch viel tun, um eben Spielort zu werden. Also es gab damals 18 deutsche Städte, die sich beworben haben. Zehn Spielorte sind es jetzt am Ende geworden. Und einige haben auch selbst im Bewerbungsverfahren festgestellt, das trauen wir uns nicht zu. Kaiserslautern wird da immer zum Beispiel als Beispiel genannt. Und andere Städte, wie zum Beispiel Bremen, die aufgrund der ganzen Vorgeschichte die Bremen ja unter anderem auch mit der DFL hat, manche Kosten eben dann doch weiter reichen hätten wollen an die Uefa oder an diese GmbH. Die wurden nicht berücksichtigt und der Schluss liegt nahe, dass es auch damit zu tun hat. Stella, wie seid ihr denn beim Korrektiv auf die Idee gekommen, euch mal diese Situation in den Ausrichterstätten näher anzusehen und was waren denn da eure Rechercheergebnisse?
Also wieso haben wir das gemacht? Ich glaube, diese diese Kostenfrage, die schwingt ja bei jedem Turnier immer mit. Und was ist man gesellschaftlich politisch bereit für diesen Groß-Event zu bezahlen? Und was kostet das letztendlich die deutschen Steuerzahlenden oder die Allgemeinheit in dem Moment? Und die Städte sind da tatsächlich sehr unterschiedlich mit umgegangen, auch gerade im Bezug auf mögliche Einnahmenkalkulationen oder was so einzelne Details wie zum Beispiel Versammlungsfreiheit und Co. angeht, die ja auch in den Verträgen der Uefa geregelt ist. Und letztendlich haben wir schon das Gefühl gewonnen, die Städte kaufen da nicht die Katze im Sack, weil letztendlich weiß man, glaube ich, worauf man sich einlässt, wenn man sich um so ein Event bewirbt. Aber was in diesen sieben Jahren der Planung alles passiert, Corona, Inflation, Energiekrise, eine ganz angespannte Sicherheitslage. Damit konnte man ja 2017 überhaupt nicht kalkulieren. Das heißt, das Risiko, das ist schon da für die Städte. Die Rückendeckung der Uefa aber nicht. Also die Städte tragen die Hauptverantwortung für dieses Turnier.
Matthias, du hast viel genickt. Du hast ja auch unter anderem mit den Botschaftern in den Städten, in den Ausrichterstätten, dass wir auch zum Teil mit Menschen gesprochen. Das deckt sich mit deinen Eindrücken.
Ja, total. Die nehmen ja sogar das Wort Knebelvertrag in den Mund und hatten am Ende aber keine Alternative. Also ich war in Dortmund unterwegs. Die verstehen sich ja als die Fußballhauptstadt Deutschlands. So sehen sie sich gerne. Und ich glaube, das ist einfach für eine Stadt wie Dortmund alternativlos. Also sie können natürlich sagen, unterschreiben wir nicht, ist uns zu viel Risiko. Mit dem Risiko oder mit der Gefahr, dass man dann die EM nicht spielt. Aber es ist natürlich in Dortmund keine Option. Also ein Fußballturnier in Deutschland und das große Stadion ist nicht dabei und die Stadt, die Fußball atmet, das kann man den eigenen Bürgern auch nicht verkaufen, wenn der Stadtrat sagt, nee, machen wir nicht mit. Von daher ist der Hebel natürlich relativ gering. Man hätte nur einen Hebel gehabt, wenn man sich mit allen Ausrichterstätten gemeinsam entschieden hätte, zu sagen, so das sind unsere Regeln hier. Dann müsste er halt in anderen, kleineren Städten ohne große Stadion spielen, was ja keine Option ist für die Uefa. Aber das hat es nicht gegeben und deswegen sind die Verträge so, wie sie sind. Und tatsächlich ist es, glaube ich, vor allen Dingen ein Wort, was man immer hört, das heißt Blankoscheck. Also man unterschreibt 2017 einen Vertrag oder nach 2017, man lässt sich auf Bedingungen ein und man weiß ja nicht, wie sich die Weltlage entwickelt. Man konnte 2017 nicht absehen, dass der islamistische Terror beispielsweise jetzt wieder so ein Thema in Deutschland wird. Stichwort Mannheim und auf einmal irgendwelche Einzeltäter, die mit Messern wahllos auf Menschen losgehen. Und allein das sorgt ja für Mehrkosten der Städte. Weil wie will man Innenstädte, wie will man Kneipen und Fan-Treffs absichern, die jetzt nicht die großen Fanzonen, die großen Stadien sind, wo auch die Uefa und die Bundespolizei dann vor Ort ist. Energiekrise ist, die Stella hat es gesagt, also es gibt da tausend Themen und das ist natürlich für viele Städte schon auch ein Faktor. Also ich nehme noch eine andere Stadt kurz mit rein, Gelsenkirchen, nicht weit weg von Dortmund. Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, wenn man sich mal so ein bisschen umguckt, wie so die Lage in Gelsenkirchen ist, die haben eigentlich keinen Euro übrig, den sie zu viel ausgeben können. Und da muss man natürlich schon wissen, was einem das wert ist.
Das haben wir ja zum Beispiel, prominentes Beispiel ist da natürlich mal wieder Berlin auch. Berlin, riesige Haushaltslöcher, da Geistern zahlen von bis zu 500 Millionen Euro rum, die eingespart werden müssen. Aber allein für die zwei Fan-Mine, die man bereitstellen muss, also das ist verpflichtend, dass das jeder Ausrichterort macht, muss man 24 Millionen Euro zahlen und insgesamt summieren sich dann auch die Mehrkosten, die entstanden sind. Stella, kannst du uns vielleicht mal kurz so durch die Themen durchführen? Was mussten denn die Spielorte der Uefa zusichern? Um was geht es da? Weil wir haben es jetzt schon so ein bisschen grob angerissen, aber damit die Hörerinnen und Hörer das genauer vor Augen haben. Und ihr habt ja die Dokumente, ihr habt uns ja die Verträge mit Frag den Staat gemeinsam zur Verfügung gestellt. Vielen Dank nochmal dafür, war sehr interessant. Aber auch ein bisschen lang, das zu lesen.
Ja, du sagst es schon, es ist lang. Also die Städte unterschreiben erst mal diese Tournament-Requirements. Die sind 190 Seiten lang und da geht es erst mal um sehr viele Zusicherungen, die die Städte machen müssen. Also das ist verpflichtend und bindend, auch wenn das noch gar nicht so konkretisiert wird, worum es eigentlich geht. Und dann gibt es eben diverse weitere Dokumente, sich Side-Letter, also solche Zusatzvereinbarungen, wo dann eben konkretisiert wird, worauf die Städte sich eigentlich konkret eingelassen haben. Das sind dann zum Beispiel die Fan-Zones, die du genannt hast und da geht es von den Ausgaben von Bis. Also Berlin zahlt da eben sehr viel Geld für mit 24 Millionen Euro. Es geht aber auch darum, dass die Städte eine interne Organisationsstruktur schaffen müssen, um DFB und Uefa während des Turniers zu unterstützen. Die Host-Cities oder die die Aussichtungsstädte, die müssen an prominenten Plätzen der Stadt das ganze Event bewerben. Die Uefa zahlt dafür nichts, also das macht auch die Stadt. Und die ganzen Kosten wie Volunteers, die hier unterstützen. Also da sind die Kosten auf in den Städten sehr unterschiedlich. Ich meine, Berlin gibt dabei schon fast eine Million für aus, für die Menschen, die dann da freiwillig unterstützen und das event mitorganisieren. Und ja, es gibt so diverse Kostenpunkte, die sich durch diese Verträge durchziehen.
Matthias, du hast so genickt, dass ich glaube, du hast auch diese 190 Seiten, zumindest die habe ich auch gelesen.
Ja, es ist ja faszinierend, was da alles geregelt ist. Also ich finde es ja auch auf einer Seite fast schon kurios faszinierend. Also es ist ja wirklich alles geregelt, bis hin zum Wasserdruck, der am Stadion aus den Leitungen kommen muss, die Anzahl der Bankplätze in der Schiedsrichterkabine, die Sitzbreite in der WIP-Tribüne. Es ist ja wirklich jede Kleinigkeit, es ist ja alles bis ins Kleinste geregelt. Und dann kommt es natürlich darauf an, wer trägt am Ende das Risiko? Und alle Rechnungen, die jetzt noch kommen könnten, alle Mehrkosten, die trägt eben nicht mehr die Uefa, weil da haben wir ja schon gehört, die Rechnung ist eigentlich schon abgeschlossen. Die wissen schon, was sie am Ende verbuchen wollen für die nächsten vier Jahre, ihren Haushalt finanzieren wollen damit. Also das ist wirklich schon bemerkenswert, aber so funktionieren leider irgendwie so Großveranstaltungen. Auch in IOC, Paris wird ein ähnliches Lied singen können. Auch einer der Gründe, warum Deutschland sich mit olympischen Bewerbungen immer so schwer tut, das ist einfach was, wo vor allen Dingen die großen Dachorganisationen des Sports profitieren und die Gastgeberstädte sich am Ende, ich sag mal, die weiche Währung, Image gewinnen, auf die Fahnen schreiben dürfen. Wie man das dann messen kann, ist nochmal eine andere Rechnung.
Ich würde da so grob zwei Themenkomplexe unterscheiden wollen bei diesen Zusagen, die man für die Uefa macht. Denn dass die Uefa bis hin auf die Sitzbreite und auch jeder Stadonsitz muss 50 Zentimeter breit sein und so weiter. Und es muss für, ich glaube, 75 männliche Personen je ein Urinal geben und für 50 weibliche Personen eine Toilette. Das sind ja alles im Stadion befindliche Dinge, die ja auch für einen reibungslosen Ablauf der Spiele sorgen. Und ich finde, das ist sehr leicht nachvollziehbar. Ob es da bis zum Wasserdruck runtergehen muss, weiß ich nicht. Aber das ist nachvollziehbar, warum die Uefa mitspricht. Für mich hat eine andere Qualität, ich weiß nicht, wie du das siehst, Stella, was dann Eingriff in die Städte selbst, ins Stadtbild selbst betrifft. Also eben zum Beispiel kostenlose Werbeflächen, kann man auf der einen Seite verstehen. Auf der anderen Seite entgehen ja den Städten dadurch allen Namen von Werbepartnern, die sonst dort geworben hätten. Dann haben wir die Fansons, die es eben geben muss. Und für die es ja dann auch richtige Bannmeilen fast schon gibt, innerhalb derre gewisse Dinge nicht durchgeführt werden dürfen. Ist das vielleicht so die Unterscheidung, die man treffen muss? Denn wir alle verstehen ja, warum im Stadion alles bis zum letzten Zentimeter Grasnabel durchorganisiert sein sollte, damit es gut funktioniert. Aber dass man ins Stadtbild so eingreift, ist ja dann doch bemerkenswert.
Ja, ich sehe das ähnlich. Also ich finde, es gibt so viele Details in den Verträgen, über die kann man vielleicht schwunzeln und das kann man auch absurd finden, was da eben auf diesen 190 Seiten alles geregelt worden ist. Aber die Fanzones und das Stadtbild und das ist ja das, wofür dann die Allgemeinheit letztendlich auch aufkommen muss. Und das sind die Dinge, die dann auch kosten.
Ja und das interessante ist, uns werden natürlich diese Fanzones, ist eigentlich lustig, dass ich jetzt auch diesen Marketingbegriff verwende, die werden uns ja so verkauft wie die Orte der Begegnung. Und da finden ja auch gute Sachen statt. Also das ist ja auch der zentrale Anlaufpunkt. Wenn ich eben sehen will, was machen denn die albanischen Fans so, dann gehe ich erstmal dorthin und gucke, ob die sich da versammelt haben. Aber gleichzeitig, Matthias, haben wir uns daran ja auch schon gewöhnt, dass wenn ein Turnier stattfindet, dass es nicht nur im Stadion einen Ort gibt, wo alle hin pilgern, sondern dass es auch diesen Ort gibt. Und dieser ist aber ja immer gleich. Also du sagst, es ist jetzt das fünfte Turnier für dich. Es würde mich sehr wundern, wenn du in irgendeine deutsche Fanzone kommst, und du denkst, Mensch, das haben die dir aber toll gelöst. Das hat aber richtig Lokalkolorit hier. Sondern meiner Prognose nach, die sehen ja immer gleich aus. Das ist, als wäre man an einem Flughafen.
Ja, Lokalkolorit ist ja nicht. Also das ist ja auch durchgestylt, weil es ja auch da Sponsoring-Partner gibt. Das Einzige, was es, glaube ich, tatsächlich gibt, Stella, du weißt es vielleicht besser, ich glaube, Köln hat sich ausbedungen, ein anderes Bier in der Fanzone auschecken zu dürfen, weil man in Köln statt Kölsch trinkt und nicht Pilz. Aber ich war halt in Frankreich, in Russland. Man trinkt halt das Bier des Sponsors, es gibt das Essen des Sponsors. Im Zweifelsfall ist das eine Fastfood-Kette, die wir alle ganz gut kennen aus den USA, die dann da auch eine Filiale in der Fanzone eröffnet natürlich. Da ist nicht viel mit Lokalkolorit. Es geht höchstens darum, wenn irgendwelche Konzerte sind an spielfreien Tagen, dass dann irgendwelche lokalen Bands oder so auftreten. Oder natürlich der Kommentar der Live-Übertragung in der Sprache des Landes ist. Also in Paris am Eiffelturm wurde natürlich französisch kommentiert auf der Leinwand. Aber ansonsten ist das alles sehr durchgestylt und Corporate-Design steht überall inzwischen bei großen Fußballturnieren. Und das ist dann auch fast schon egal, ob ich in Hamburg, in Köln, in München oder in Doha auf der Fanzone bin.
Ich glaube, Köln hat sich vor allem dafür ausgesprochen, dann nur lokale Künstler innen einzuladen. Also da haben die Städte freie Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten, aber sonst ja und es ist so absurd, weil die Uefa ja argumentiert, die Städte hätten freie Hand aus dem Turnier das zu machen, was sie machen wollen. Ja, in den Verträgen liest sich das zumindest anders, ja.
Ja, und auch in den Gesprächen, die man haben kann, mit Menschen vor Ort, die etwas organisieren. Also egal, um was es da geht, um die kleinen Fragen oder die großen Fragen, eigentlich wird immer gesagt, na die Uefa hat gesagt das und deswegen machen wir also diese freie Hand, die schwer zu erkennen. Und ich finde, das hat ja zwei Aspekte. Das eine ist ein Aspekt, auf den werden wir später nochmal zu sprechen kommen, weil man kann ja durchaus damit argumentieren, der Imagegewinn durch solche Turniere, der ist da und der kann sich auch wirtschaftlich niederschlagen. Die Frage ist aber, wie groß ist dieser Imagegewinn, wenn die Fanzone in München genauso aussieht wie in Köln? Also da muss ich ja dann schon quasi rausgehen aus der Fanzone, um irgendwie noch etwas mit dieser Stadt zu verbinden. Und der zweite Aspekt, und bei dem würde ich jetzt gerne mal kurz bleiben, ist ja das, es greift ja nicht nur ins Stadtbild ein, sondern es verdrängt ja auch andere. Also diese Fans arent sind ja nicht irgendwie im Industriegebiet weit draußen, sondern die sind mitten in der Innenstadt. Da gibt es andere Bars, Cafés, Restaurants, Kulturbetriebe, Kinos, Theater und so weiter. Und die werden ja auch alle in diese Bannzone zum Teil mit reingelegt. Was haben denn da eure Recherchenergebens, Stella, welche Konfliktszonen es da vielleicht auch gibt und können da irgendwie die lokalen Geschäfte eigentlich mitreden?
Dazu kann ich leider gar nicht viel sagen. Also in unserer Recherche ging es vor allem um eben die Verträge mit der Stadt und Uefa. Ich kann davon meine persönlichen Erfahrungen berichten, wie es mir vielleicht auch als Nicht-Fußball-Fan geht und dann auch in der Stadt wie Dortmund und so. Aber vielleicht ist Matthias hier bei der Frage der bessere Ansprechpartner.
Ich kann halt ein ganz prominentes Beispiel nehmen, hier aus Köln, wo unser Funkhaus ja steht, wo ich auch gerade sitze. Wir haben in Köln ja einige feste Termine im Jahr, so wie den Rosenmontag, wo die Stadt Kopf steht. Und es gibt genauso das 1. Juli-Wochenende, wo der Christopher Street Day relativ groß gefeiert wird in Köln, vielleicht auch die größte Parade in Deutschland hat. Das kollidiert aber mit dem Achtelfinale, was auch in Köln stattfindet, und noch mehr mit der Fan-Zone, die auf dem Heumarkt stattfindet, weil das wäre eigentlich ein traditioneller Spielort der Parade. Und so ist unter ziemlich viel heftiger Diskussion der Christopher Street Day jetzt drei Wochen nach hinten verlegt worden, eine Woche oder zwei Wochen nach hinten verlegt worden, eine Woche nach das EM-Finale. Und es hat viele schon verstört, weil das seit vielen Jahren ein total fixer Termin ist, wo ja jetzt auch nicht wenige Leute nach Köln kommen. Ich glaube, wir reden da ja auch über mehrere hunderttausend Menschen. Und aus Stadtsicht verständlich, man kann nicht irgendwie zwei so Riesenveranstaltungen wahrscheinlich adäquat absichern und abdecken. Aber es zeigt, glaube ich, ganz einfach, wenn so eine Europameisterschaft kommt, dann hat alles andere erst mal Pause.
Und gleichzeitig haben wir ja auch noch andere Eingriffe. Also es geht da nicht nur um die lokalen Barbetreiber und so weiter und so fort und die lokale Wirtschaft, sondern es geht ja auch um ganz grundlegende Dinge, wie z.B. Grundrechte, nämlich das Grundrecht z.B. zu Meinungsäußerungen. Also Stella, ein Teil, der eben auch nicht stattfinden darf innerhalb dieser Fan-Sauce, ist jede politisch geartete Meinungsäußerung. Jetzt gibt es da Experten, die sagen, wenn das vor Gericht geht, wird das definitiv gekippt. Dafür braucht es aber natürlich sowohl einen Anlass als auch einen Kläger. Und der beklagt das in dem Fall richtig klar. Aber kannst du uns noch mal da mitnehmen, was bedeutet es denn, diese Bannzone zu haben rund um diese Fans, in denen nicht nur bestimmte Sponsoren nur auftragen dürfen exklusiv, sondern in dem die Uefa sich ja auch herausnimmt, darüber zu bestimmen, wie sich Menschen verhalten?
Also wie das Wort Bannmeilen und Bannzone es schon sagt, eigentlich ist erst mal alles verboten, was von der Uefa nicht konkret erlaubt wird. Und da nimmt sie sich eben auch raus, politische Demonstrationen und Co. verbiegen zu wollen oder nicht stattfinden lassen zu wollen. Und die Städte haben uns auf die Frage, wie sie dazu stehen und inwiefern das denn mit dem Grundgesetz vereinbart ist, ob ganz unterschiedlich darauf geantwortet. Manche Städte sagen, es gibt so ein Verbot nicht. Andere Städte wie Berlin sagen, ja, wir müssen das ausbalancieren, die Bedeutung dieses Festes, aber auch eben das Recht auf diese politischen Protest. Und so richtig konkret wurde da aber niemand. Die Frage ist, was würde passieren, wenn denn tatsächlich so eine Demonstration angemeldet werden würde innerhalb dieser Bandmeilen, was dann passieren würde?
Wenn ich tippen müsste, würde ich sagen, die Sicherheitsbehörden lassen es nicht zu und sagen an einem anderen Ort sehr gerne, aber hier nicht. Aber das ist...
Man würde wahrscheinlich einen Kompromiss suchen, aber tatsächlich ist es ja so, dass letztlich sollte es da auch eine unangemeldete Demonstration geben oder irgendwelche Menschen, die dann da Banner hochhalten oder demonstrieren, müssten die Sicherheitsbehörden tatsächlich immer im Einzelfall auch abwägen, ob nicht hier tatsächlich Meinungsfreiheit wichtiger ist als Uefa-Turnier-Durchführungsbestimmung. Es ist ein spannender Punkt. Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass der ein oder andere uns auch darauf ankommen lassen wird. Also wir haben ja bei der letzten EM, die auch in München stattgefunden hat, unter anderem diesen Greenpeace-Protest im Stadion sogar gehabt, der ein bisschen verunglückt ist, weil er nicht ganz die Kurve getroffen hat, die er wollte. Aber auf sowas sind die Ausrichter eingestellt. Also das sagen die Organisatoren auch ganz klar. Man wird es nicht verhindern können und sie müssen sich darauf einstellen, dass irgendein Szenario eintreten wird während dieser Europameisterschaft.
Und dann haben wir eben die grundsätzlichen Kosten. Und da würde ich gerne noch mal näher drauf eingehen. Also ich weiß zum Beispiel, Stella, es war sehr interessant. Ich habe quasi eure Recherche natürlich gelesen und ich habe den Beitrag von Matthias gehört. Ich saß aber auch in einer Veranstaltung, in der jemand von dieser Euro 2024 GmbH mal präsentiert hat, was es alles so zu diesem Turnier gibt. Matthias grins schon so, ich glaube, in dieser Veranstaltung warst du auch zugeschaltet. Und da wurde uns zum Beispiel erzählt, Mensch in Berlin toll, Brandenburger Tor, wir rollen einen Kunstrasen aus, aber keine Sorge, es wird trotzdem alles ganz nachhaltig sein. Und guck mal, wir haben hier LED-Pennis, die gehen irgendwie über 24 Meter, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, aber weil die Sichtachse so durch das Brandenburger Tor nicht gestört werden darf, sind die modular, das heißt, sie fahren auf die Seite und klappen sich weg, damit die Sichtachse da ist, wenn keine Spiele laufen und wenn dann ein Spiel läuft, dann wird diese tolle riesige LED-Wand zusammengefahren und wieder aufgebaut. Und ich habe auch schon Fotos von vor Ort bekommen, es ist enorm, was da aufgetischt wird und es ist sehr, sehr groß. Mal wieder, was da veranstaltet wird. Es ist ja aber auch sehr, sehr teuer. Kannst du uns mal so ein bisschen durch die Städte führen? Ihr habt ja da auch eine schöne Gesamtübersicht gezeigt. Was sind denn so die Kosten, die da für die Städte anfallen und vielleicht auch die Mehrkosten?
Also so ganz detailliert kann ich es dir leider nicht beantworten. Wir mussten uns ja in unseren Anfragen auch irgendwie beschränken, um noch rechtzeitig ausreichend Antworten zu bekommen, wie das immer so ist bei Presseanfragen. Aber also allein in Berlin werden 83 Millionen Euro aktuell kalkuliert für diese Europameisterschaft. Das sind 40 Millionen mehr als ursprünglich mal angedacht. Und jetzt ist Berlin natürlich ein sehr extremes Beispiel. Aber auch in Städten wie, ich meine, Frankfurt hat sich das fast verdoppelt an Kosten. Also da sprechen wir irgendwie von ursprünglich 17 Millionen Euro, die mal einkalkuliert wurden. Und jetzt sind wir bei 30. Aber man muss auch dazu sagen, dass wir gar nicht von allen Städten Antworten dazu bekommen haben. Also Hamburg, Düsseldorf und Stuttgart haben uns nicht sagen können, was denn mal ursprünglich ihr kalkuliertes Budget für dieses Event war. Also in Stuttgart hieß es, es gibt halt gar keine Kalkulation, mit denen man irgendwann mal aufgeschlagen hätte, was auch schon wieder absurd ist. Ja, also wir sprechen hier von 66 Millionen Euro, die mindestens dazugekommen sind an Kosten seit den ersten Planungen der Städte. Aber vermutlich waren das noch einige Millionen Euro mehr, die wir einfach nicht mit einkalkulieren konnten, weil wir es nicht wissen.
Summiert sich dann auf Gesamtausgaben, eben bei aller Vorsicht, weil muss natürlich eine Schätzung sein, 295 Millionen Euro. Ich würde jetzt einfach von dreieinhalb Millionen Euro die Freiheit würde ich mir rausnehmen. Dreieinhalb Millionen Ausgaben für die Städte. Und die waren sich dessen ja auch bewusst. Also Matthias, wir haben es ja zum Beispiel bei Dortmund. Wissen wir, da gibt es inzwischen Auszüge aus einer nichtöffentlichen Beschlussvorlage, wo man überlegt hat, wollen wir uns denn als Ausrichterstadt bewerben? Und da stand schon drin. Also das finanzielle Risiko, das ist da, im Grunde ist es eigentlich kaum kalkulierbar. Und das war ja noch vor Energiekrise und vor, wir brauchen jetzt noch mehr Sicherheitspersonal und so weiter an den Fanzones. Also die Städte wussten, worauf sie sich einlassen, haben aber offenbar den Zwang gespürt, wir müssen das machen.
Ja, genau aus der Überlegung. Also wie kann so ein Turnier in Deutschland stattfinden, wenn Dortmund nicht dabei ist? Also ich glaube, das sind ähnliche Fragen, wenn sie auch Berlin und München gestellt haben. Das sind einfach die Orte mit den großen Stadien, die man erwartet, auch bei so einem Turnier. Von daher ist das am Ende alternativlos. Man kann dann probieren, hier und da auch im 1 zu 1 Kontakt mit der Uefa noch kleinere Stellschräubchen zu drehen. Aber das grundsätzliche Ja zu dieser EM, ich glaube, wenn man in Dortmund ehrlich ist, hat das immer festgestanden. Man musste natürlich das in der Kommunikation auch so angehen, dass man da gut aus dieser Situation rauskommt. Aber ich würde mal behaupten, es hat keiner wirklich daran gezweifelt, dass dieses Turnier in Dortmund stattfinden wird. Ich weiß, dass sie natürlich versucht haben, hinter den Kulissen auch noch was anzustoßen, weil es auch für Dortmund nicht so einfach ist, glaube ich, finanziell und wirtschaftlich. Aber grundsätzlich war das klar, die müssen mitmachen.
Und dann fand ich noch einen Aspekt interessant. Da würde mich auch deine Meinung zu interessieren, nämlich die Volunteers. Die Volunteers sind immer ein großes Thema bei so Großveranstaltungen, denn das sind also in die Zehntausenden hinein geht es an Volunteers. Und das ist immer so eine merkwürdige Diss-Balance, dass du dann Pressekonferenzen hast mit Janin Infantino bei der FIFA oder dem Alexander Zeverin bei der Uefa. Da wird dann den Volunteers laut gedankt. Soll ja auch so sein. Und Mensch, toll, ohne euch wäre dieses Turnier nicht möglich gewesen. Und dann Schnitt eine halbe Stunde weiter vorne und dann wird gesagt, so wir haben jetzt wieder 1,7 Milliarden Euro eingenommen. Das ist alles ganz toll gelaufen. Aber diese Volunteers werden ja zum Teil gar nicht bezahlt. Was die Städte in Teilen aber tun. Kannst du da mal noch deine Gedanken zu fassen? Wie passt denn das eigentlich zusammen? Warum ist das immer noch so bei allen Turnieren?
Ich glaube, da macht sich die Uefa was zu Nutze, was eben spürbar ist. Viele Menschen haben einfach, Stella vielleicht jetzt nicht, aber viele Menschen haben einfach Bock auf dieses Turnieren. Die wollen gerne teil sein. Sie wollen gerne später sich erinnern und in zehn Jahren denken, hier als die EM in Deutschland war, wie auch immer sie dann sportlich vom Wetter oder von sonstigen Rahmenbedingungen ausgeht, diese vier Wochen, dass man dann sagen kann, ich war irgendwie dabei. Ob ich jetzt ein Volontier war, der irgendwie am Bahnhof gestanden hat und versucht hat, den Weg zum Stadion zu zeigen, ob ich irgendwo in einem Pressebereich gearbeitet habe und dann vielleicht auch ein paar Einblicke hinter die Kulissen bekommen habe, weil ich dann irgendwie den BBC-Kollegen bei der Arbeit zu gucken konnte oder so. Also es gibt ja schon viele Bereiche, die einfach auch einen Reiz ausmachen, wo man sagen will, so, ich habe Bock, da jetzt was zu machen und ich will jetzt irgendwie gerne mithelfen. Ich glaube, da macht sich die Uefa schon zunutze, dass viele Leute einfach ein bisschen teilhaben wollen von diesem großen Kuchen Europameisterschaft.
Habt ihr Einblicke, Stella, wie die Ausgaben der Städte sich so grob verteilen? Also die Fans, die machen so rund 30 Prozent bis zu einem Drittel aus, Viertel bis ein Drittel ungefähr. Das heißt, wir haben ja noch einen großen Teil der Kosten von rund 300 Millionen Euro mit dem Sternchen dran, das ich vorhin gemacht habe, die woanders hinfließen müssen.
Ja, das ist auch von Stadt zu Stadt ganz unterschiedlich. Ich habe es mir schon mal angerissen. Für diese Volunteers geben die Städte auch wirklich sehr unterschiedliche Summen an Geld aus. Berlin mit 800.000 Euro eben fast eine Million. Andere Städte sind da wiederum günstiger, wie Köln. Die zahlen da für 300, ja knapp 300.000 Euro. Auch dieses Host City Dressing, also dass die Städte eben die EM populär bewerben an prominenten Plätzen der Stadt, ist eben auch ganz unterschiedlich. Berlin zahlt dafür 4 Millionen, eine Stadt wie Hamburg knapp 800.000. Also wir können nicht sagen, das ist der Kostenfaktor, weil die Städte da dann doch ihren eigenen Handlungsspielraum haben. Ich denke aber, was für alle Städte vermutlich ähnlich teuer und schwer kalkulierbar wird, sind die ganzen Sicherheitskosten, die ja auch noch nicht final stehen. Also deutschlandweit werden die, ich meine, auf 150 Millionen Euro geschätzt. Aber was es dann letztendlich kostet, weiß ja noch niemand.
Und das ist ja vor allem insofern interessant, wenn wir über die Städte sprechen, da können wir auch gleich nochmal dazu kommen, die erhoffen sich ja auch etwas von dieser EM und werden ja auch Einnahmen auf der Gegenseite haben. Was aber diese Sicherheitskosten angeht, die werden von uns allen getragen. Auch von Bundesländern wird da mitbezahlt, die gar keine Host-Cities haben. Und gleichzeitig ist das ein sehr schwer kalkulierbarer Bereich. Also 150 Millionen Euro ist die minimale Schätzung, die der Spiegel in einer verwandten Recherche abgegeben hat. Ich werde natürlich alles verlinken, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, findet ihr dann in den Show Notes. Allein die Koordinierungsstelle der Polizei in Neuss soll 10 Millionen Euro kosten, also nur eben der Ort, an dem für dieses Turnier über die Sicherheit koordiniert wird. Und da haben wir ja, Matthias, auch einen ganz sensiblen Punkt erreicht. Denn natürlich sind Polizeikosten anders zu bewerten. Die sind zum einen schwerer kalkulierbar und ein Stück weit wollen wir ja auch, dass da lieber, also da sollte man jetzt nicht geizen, um es jetzt mal so zu sagen, während ich bei den Volunteergehältern ein bisschen strenger wäre. Aber kannst du mal uns ein Gefühl dafür geben, also 150 Millionen Euro Minimum, das ist ja einiges und das wird von uns allen als SteuerzahlerInnen getragen, ohne dass es ja mal eine Abstimmung darüber gegeben hätte. Also wie denkst du über diesen ganzen Bereich?
Ja klar, Sicherheit ist natürlich, nennt sie Feser, die Innenministerin, hat er gesagt, er hat oberste Priorität, das ist das entscheidende Thema, also gerade nach so Vorfällen wie in Mannheim, glaube ich. Ich habe bei einem Punkt, habe ich sehr aufgemerkt, ich hatte ein Interview vor einiger Zeit mit Herbert Reul, das ist der Innenminister in Nordrhein-Westfalen, der hat hier, in NRW sind ja vier von zehn Stadien oder anders ausgedrückt 20 von 51 Spielen finden hier statt. Das heißt, der trägt quasi auch die Hauptsicherheitslast als für eben die Polizei verantwortlicher Minister. Und der hat sehr klar und deutlich gesagt, während der Europameisterschaft haben in ganz Deutschland alle Polizisten Urlaubssperre. Allein da wissen wir schon, was einen Teil der Kosten ausmacht. Also von Flensburg bis Garmisch-Partenkirchen oder Oberstdorf sind alle Polizisten im Einsatz und werden überall da eingesetzt, wo sie gebraucht werden. Auch wenn sie mit dem Turnier natürlich überhaupt nichts zu tun haben. Auch die wird es ja unter den Polizisten geben. Das ist natürlich ein großes Thema. Und dann diese Absprachen auch. Das betrifft jetzt nicht nur Sicherheit vor Terror. Also es gibt ja Sicherheit vor Cyberkriminalität zum Beispiel, war ein großes Thema im Vorfeld, als der Islamismus noch nicht den großen Scheinwerfer bekommen hat. Also wie sichern wir zum Beispiel auch ein Turnier, was komplett digital ausgestattet ist. Wir haben Einlasskontrollen, die sind digital. Es ist wirklich alles digital. Und da muss man natürlich auch cybermäßig sich vorbereiten. Wir haben das Fan-Thema. Welche Fans kommen hierhin? Wie werden die gelenkt? Alleine das reine Lenken der Personensträume braucht ja schon eine Menge von Sicherheitskräften. Und da ist natürlich, das ist klar, also bei insgesamt 12 Millionen, die man erwartet, kumuliert, das kostet eine Menge. Ich schätze, den meisten wird es das auch wert sein, weil eben Sicherheit tatsächlich für alle das Wichtigste ist. Aber ja, man kann natürlich schon mal fragen, ob nicht die Uefa als Ausrichter, so wie es Bremen ja auch gemacht hat mit der DFL, zumindest einen Teil der Kosten mittragen sollte.
Kommt man natürlich auch schnell in grundsätzliche Debatten rein, aber ich fand es halt insofern interessant, Stella. Wir haben hier Kosten, wie gesagt, schwer zu schätzen, aber 150 Millionen Euro Aufwärts. Und gleichzeitig ist die Steuerersparnis, die die Uefa bekommen hat, durch die Körperschaftssteuer, die sie nicht zahlen muss, also eigentlich müsste sie 15 Prozent der Einkünfte versteuern, das wären rund 250 Millionen Euro. Also würde man in Anführungszeichen nur diese Körperschaftssteuer nehmen, dann hätte man sehr wahrscheinlich diese Kosten eigentlich damit ganz gut abgedeckt. Und das ist natürlich ein schiefer Vergleich, weil unterschiedliche Kostentöpfe und so weiter. Aber da finde ich, merkt man dann schon, wie kritisch es dann doch ist, sich auf so etwas einzulassen, in dem Wissen, sonst kriegen wir dieses Turnier nicht. Deswegen musste Ola Scholz im Unterkanzlerin Angela Merkel diese Zusage treffen. Ansonsten hätte das nicht in Deutschland stattgefunden. Aber ich finde, das ist schon ein Punkt, den man nicht vergessen sollte bei so einem Turnier.
Absolut. Zumal für die Uefa ja auch anscheinend im Vorhinein alles sehr gut planbar erscheinen. Also wenn jetzt eben schon klar ist, okay, wir machen hier einen Rekordgewinn von 2,4 Milliarden, was einen Gewinn von ungefähr 1,7 Milliarden bedeutet im Endeffekt. Und für die Städte funktioniert das eben nicht. Oder für die Allgemeinheit und den Bund und Länder, die eben Kosten tragen. Und wenn man dann wiederum die andere Seite sieht, die Städte, die eben gar nicht genau sagen können, was bleibt denn finanziell tatsächlich hängen, finde ich das schon absurd, dass man sich als Uefa mit so einer Monopolstellung so viel rausnehmen kann in dem Moment.
Und warum ist das so, Matthias?
Wer die große Bühne hat, bestimmt irgendwie auch die Regeln. Also dieses Turnier ist halt so wahnsinnig groß geworden. Ich habe es jetzt noch mal einfach nachgelesen, auch in der Vorbereitung auf das Turnier, weil das ist schon bemerkenswert, wie sich einfach die Einnahmen auch verändert haben. Also zu Beginn des Jahrtausends, was gefühlt noch gar nicht lange her ist, lagen die Einnahmen bei nicht mal einem Zehntel. Da hat die ganze EM 200 Millionen Kosten verursacht oder Umsatz gebracht für die Uefa. Und das ist jetzt auch durch die Fernsehrechte immer weiter gestiegen. Wir reden jetzt von dem Zwölffachen inzwischen, was so ein Turnier bringt. In den letzten beiden oder drei Ausgaben exorbitant nach oben geschossen. Und man hat es einfach geschafft, man redet ja heute viel von Marken, eine Marke zu etablieren, eine Aufmerksamkeit weltweit zu schaffen für ein Turnier. Weil ebenso viele Leute daran partizipieren wollen, weil so viele Leute was davon abbekommen wollen von der Aufmerksamkeit. Das gilt ja auch für die Gastgeberstätte, das gilt für die Gastgeberländer. Ein kleines Beispiel, die ukrainische Mannschaft, die ja kommen wird zu dem Turnier, schläft in Taunusstein, einer kleinen Kommune in Hessen. Die einzige Mannschaft, die in Hessen unterkommt. Ich habe mit dem Bürgermeister gesprochen und der sagt, das ist eine einmalige Chance für uns im Zusammenhang mit der EM, irgendwie erwähnt zu werden. Und wenn du bei ein paar Leuten Taunusstein übrig bleibst, für ihn absolut essentiell und ein Jackpot, dass die Ukraine jetzt zu ihm in die Stadt kommt, bei allem Aufwand und bei allen Sicherheitsaufwendungen, die sie jetzt gerade für die Ukraine machen müssen. Es überregt die absolute Vorfreude, weil sie jetzt irgendwie hoffen, ein paar Krümel von dieser EM auch für Taunusstein abziehen zu können. Also das macht, glaube ich, ganz gut die Dimension deutlich, was das bedeutet, einfach irgendwie im Zusammenhang mit dieser Euro teilzuhaben, genannt zu werden oder was auch immer.
Und da sind wir ja bei einem interessanten Punkt, nämlich bei der Frage, was gewinnen denn sowohl die Spielstädte als auch jetzt eben dann hier so kleinere Orte. Ich glaube, bei den kleineren Orten ist es einfacher, weil über die würde einfach sonst gar nicht berichtet werden. Das ist relativ eindeutig, dass das natürlich einen auch touristischen Effekt hat. Aber Stella, was die großen Städte angeht, ist das ja durchaus umstritten. Und wir haben ja schon die Vorerfahrung. Vor 18 Jahren gab es hier schon mal ein Turnier, die WM 2006. Da war damals dann im Jahr danach die etwas ernüchternde Erkenntnis. Also eigentlich haben wir nicht mehr verdient. Wir haben sogar in den Ausrichterstätten eher weniger Umsatz gemacht, weil es so einen Couch-Potato-Effekt gab. Die Leute haben nur noch Fußball geguckt. Sie haben sonst nichts mehr gemacht. Sie waren weder shoppen noch in der Innenstadt, noch haben sie irgendwelche kulturellen Einrichtungen besucht. Wie blickst du denn auf das, was die Städte sagen, deren Antwort ja auf die steigenden Kosten immer ist? Wir werden ja auch sehr viele Einnahmen haben. Und Stuttgart sagt dann natürlich, so wie wir unsere Kosten nicht kalkulieren konnten, können wir auch die Einnahmen gar nicht kalkulieren. Also wie blickst du auf das, was reinkommt?
Also es war total spannend, wie unterschiedlich auch da die Städte geantwortet haben. Also Stuttgart in dem Fall, die auch sagen, ja, das Ganze lässt sich ja gar nicht monetarisieren, finde ich im Nachhinein sogar ehrlicher diese Antwort als diese Kostenkalkulation. Weil ich finde, wenn man als Stadt begründet, ja, wir wollen aber diesen Erlebnis nutzen für die Bevölkerung und wir wollen diese internationale Aufmerksamkeit, dann sind wir auch bereit, dafür zweiständige Millionenbeträge auszugeben. Dann ist das eine ehrliche Antwort. Aber diese Kostenkalkulation, die wir teilweise bekommen haben, also zum Beispiel von der Stadt Leipzig, die setzen sich dann zusammen aus Übernachtungsgästen, Tagesgästen und das, was eben die lokale Bevölkerung so am Tag auskriegt in der Stadt. Und die sind aber gar nicht belastbar, weil eben verschiedene Effekte entweder ignoriert werden oder fälschlicherweise mit eingerechnet werden. Also du hast es gerade schon genannt, der Couch-Potato-Effekt, dass beispielsweise Hotelgäste. Die Stadt rechnet damit, ja, wir bekommen ja so und so viele Besucher, die müssen ja alle irgendwo schlafen und die lassen dann auch Geld in der Hotellerie. Aber dass in Sommermonaten die Städte vielleicht sowieso gut ausgebucht sind und dass das eben auch bedeutet, dass andere Touristen nicht kommen können, wird dabei eben oft nicht mitbedacht. Beziehungsweise wenn wir von Tagesbesuchern sprechen, dann wird da irgendwie ein Tagessatz genannt, den die angeblich ausgeben von knapp 300 Euro am Tag. Der kommt daher, dass irgendwie so das durchschnittliche Budget von so Tagestouristen genommen wird. Und da sind dann aber auch Messebesucher mit dabei, die eben ja auch hohe Spenden bezahlt bekommen. Aber welcher Fußballfan gibt denn tatsächlich 300 Euro am Tag aus? Und genauso wie das ist mit der Lokalbevölkerung. Also es mag ja sein, dass an diesen Tagen vermehrt Leute in die Stadt gehen und was trinken, was essen. Aber ich habe ja nur ein bestimmtes Nettoeinkommen. Und wenn ich das Mitte des Monats ausgebe bei drei, vier Spielen, dann habe ich das halt Ende des Monats nicht mehr zur Verfügung. Also da können auch keine Mehrposten entstehen. Und die Leute, die dann arbeiten in der Gastronomie, die vielleicht in den Hotels arbeiten, die verdienen ja weiterhin ihren Mindestlohn und vielleicht ein bisschen Trinkgeld. Aber da kommt ja auch kein Mehr an Steuereinnahmen. Also die Frage ist, was bleibt tatsächlich finanziell bei den Städten hängen und ist das tatsächlich so viel wie behauptet wird? Und das stelle ich, oder stelle ich eine faire Recherche noch sehr in Frage, wenn da irgendwelche dreistelligen Millionenbeträge genannt werden, die die Städte angeblich damit machen.
Ich fand es interessant, habe ich bei euch ja auch gelesen, die Direktion aus Köln, so klassische Kölner. Es hat noch immer Jotje-Jange-Mentalität. Die schreiben ja einfach nur, sie können es nicht ausrechnen, sie freuen sich, gute Gastgeber zu sein und passt schon. Also das ist möglicherweise am Ende die ehrlichste Antwort, die man geben kann, weil man es am Ende wirklich nicht ausrechnen kann.
Ja, so wie es Stuttgart ja auch dann getan hat. Und gleichzeitig bringt das ja auch die Städte in eine paradoxe Situation, denn wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, korrigiert mich bitte. Aber wenn jemand in der Fan-Zone was konsumiert, das geht natürlich nicht an die lokalen Betreiber, sondern das geht ja an die Uefa oder an die gemeinsame GmbH. Und eigentlich hätten die Städte ein großes Interesse, die Leute überall hinzuschicken, außer in die Fan-Zone. Und vielleicht ja, okay, guckt euch das Spiel da an, aber ansonsten, bitte geht in unsere Bars, geht in unsere Kneipen, guckt euch hier, geht durch unsere Innenstadt und kauft die bitte leer. Aber natürlich machen sie genau das Gegenteil. Sie sagen, die Fan-Zone, das ist das, wo du hin musst, die Uefa, jeder, der ein Ticket hat, der wird jetzt schon damit auch mit Informationen zugeballert, wo man dann wo sein sollte, am besten um auch ja nichts zu verpassen. Das zeigt ja schon diese Zwickmühle, die wir vorhin auch schon beschrieben haben, die es eben jetzt letztlich auch bei der Durchführung für die Städte gibt. Das zweite Argument, was ja bestimmt auch eines ist, Stella, ist natürlich der Image-Gewinn, sowohl für Deutschland als Land, als auch für die einzelnen Orte. Das lässt sich natürlich noch viel schwerer zu beziffern. Ihr habt dazu auch mit Experten gesprochen. Was haben die denn dazu gesagt?
Ja, wir haben da mit Wolfgang Mennich gesprochen von der Uni in Hamburg. Und der hat uns schon auch ganz ehrlich und diplomatisch gesagt, dass diese Effekte nicht zu unterschätzen sind. Also dass so ein Turnier wie die Europameisterschaft eben schon einen hohen Ernebnisnutzen einmal für die lokale Bevölkerung hat, aber dann eben auch diese Außenwirkung für Deutschland innerhalb von Europa, der Welt, dass das vielleicht kurzfristige Effekte sind, aber dass er schon sagen würde, dass zweiständige Millionenbeträge dafür auch gerechtfertigt sein können, ohne dass er mir das jetzt konkret vorgerechnet hat. Also ich glaube, man kann schon abwägen, was ist uns dieses Event wert. Aber ich finde, dann sollte das auch anders kommuniziert werden nach außen.
Da schließt sich ein bisschen der Kreis Matthias dann auch zu deiner Recherche, weil du ja eben viel darüber gesprochen hast, wie der DFB, wie die Uefa dieses Turnier verkauft, als eben besonders nachhaltig, als wirtschaftlich, als sicher. Natürlich, was sollen sie auch sonst alles sagen. Aber das ist ja dann, glaube ich, der größte Kritikpunkt, den man eigentlich machen kann, dass so ein Turnier etwas kostet und dass es auch schwer zu kalkulieren ist. Das wird, denke ich, jetzt niemanden hier gerade vom Hocker gehauen haben, während er diese Podcast-Folge gehört hat. Aber auf der anderen Seite eben sichere Einnahmen, kalkulierbare Einkommen bei der Uefa zu haben, das komplette Risiko aber im Grunde beim Ausrichterland und bei den Ausrichterstätten und eben gleichzeitig aber immer zu sagen, im Grunde ist das das beste seit geschnitten Brot, das diesem ganzen Land passiert ist. Da gibt es eben eine gewisse Spannung, finde ich, zwischen diesen beiden Punkten. Und das ist vielleicht auch das, was wir hier in dieser Sendung gerade aufarbeiten.
Ja, für mich hat es sich am Ende so dargestellt, als wenn alle Beteiligten oder indirekt Beteiligten gigantische Erwartungen an dieses Turnier haben. Also das Sportliche ist natürlich klar. Der DFB will, sagen sie inzwischen auch offiziell, so Europameister werden. Sie wollen so lange möglichen Turnier sein. Das ist das Sportliche. Das ist ein Thema. Die Gastgeberstätte, wir haben viel darüber gesprochen, wollen super Image gewinnen, wollen am liebsten noch ein bisschen Geld mit dabei verdienen, ob sie es schaffen oder nicht, egal. Aber auch da, gigantische Erwartungen, Riesenparty, die Uefa sowieso, gerade auch finanziell, gigantische Erwartungen. Und dann kommt ja noch obendrauf die Politik, die dann sagt so, wir haben ein Land, wo wir hatten gerade die Wahlen zum Europaparlament und viele haben über die Wahlergebnisse mehr als nur Kopfzerbrechen bekommen. Wir haben ein Land, das in gewissen Teilen gespalten ist, wo es sogar in vielen Teilen der gesellschaftliche Dialog nicht mehr richtig funktioniert oder gar nicht mehr funktioniert, sogar in manchen Bereichen. Und jetzt haben wir die Gelegenheit mit einer EM vier Wochen lang so ein bisschen irgendeine Art von Kitt über diese Gesellschaft zu schmeißen, der alle irgendwie wieder hinter dem Fußball vereint und der irgendwie so ein Gemeinschaftsgefühl möglich macht, dass wir wieder miteinander ins Gespräch kommen, gemeinsame Erlebnisse haben. Das befeuert der DFB auch. Selbst Philipp Lahm als Turnierdirektor hat das sehr, sehr, sehr oft immer wieder gesagt. Und das greift die Politik auf, bis hin zum Bundeskanzler. Und jetzt da alle reden davon, was das für eine Chance ist. Also auch riesige Erwartungen aus der Politik. Und alle wollen irgendwas auf dieses Turnier projizieren. Und das ist, glaube ich, am Ende, hat sich zumindest so in meinen Recherchen dargestellt, so das, auf das sich alle einigen können. Wir haben hier vier Wochen vor uns und wir erwarten nichts mehr als die Quadratur des Kreises und die Rettung der Gesellschaft oder weiß ich nicht was. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch eine Gefahr. Also je höher die Erwartung, umso tiefer kann ich halt auch fallen. Und 2006 haben wir sicherlich in der Rückschau auch das ein oder andere verklärt. Und wenn da nicht vier Wochen lang bestes Wetter gewesen wäre und die deutsche Mannschaft nicht begeisternden Fußball gespielt hätte nach vorher ernüchternden Leistungen, wäre das, glaube ich, auch anders abgelaufen.
Ja, ich habe noch mal Artikel gelesen im Vorausblick auf die WM 2006. Da wurde davon ausgegangen, sieben Milliarden Euro wird das an mehr Gewinnen bringen dieses Turnier. Und es wird den Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland nach vorne bringen. Und bei all den positiven Dingen, die definitiv auch passiert sind, war aber ja dann die nüchterne Erkenntnis 2007. Ah ne, wir haben festgestellt, es hat uns eigentlich 0,1 Prozentpunkte des Bruttoinlandsproduktes gekostet, dieses Turnier verursacht zu haben. Und da ist natürlich das Auseinandergehen schon sehr heftig. Gleichzeitig spricht aber ja Matthias damit, Stella auch schon, all das an, was im Begriff Sommermärchen drinsteckt, in Anführungszeichen, der jetzt inflationär schon wieder gebraucht wird. Haben wir hier im Rasenfunk auch schon mal darüber diskutiert.
Ich bin extra darum rumgegangen.
Ich weiß das auch sehr zu schätzen, Matthias, aber die Dinge müssen beim Namen unbenannt werden.
Okay, du hast nicht 2.0 gesagt.
Ich vermute, Stella, dass ihr das auch zu spüren bekommen habt, als ihr eure Recherche veröffentlicht habt. Wie waren denn da so die Reaktionen?
Ja, paradoxerweise habe ich das gar nicht so sehr in Verbindung mit dem Märchen von Sommermärchen, wie ich das sehe, wahrgenommen. Also wenn man jetzt mal in die Kommentarspalten geguckt hat, dann hat man auch schon gelesen, dass viele Leute schon frustriert sind, dass so viel Geld für dieses Event ausgegeben wird. Und ich also ich stelle mir auch immer die Frage, okay, diese Hoffnung von Zusammenhalt und wir schauen jetzt alle gemeinsam Fußball und stoßen gemeinsam an und vergessen mal kurz die Sorgen. Ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass das tatsächlich gesellschaftlich gerade so sehr gelebt wird. Also die Umstände sind ja nun mal die, die wir gerade haben. Die gehen ja durch vier Wochen Fußball nicht weg. Also wenn ich jetzt an meinen Motionskreis denke, da ist niemand, der sagt, die Wahlergebnisse letzte Woche, die waren aber gruselig. Aber naja, jetzt gucken wir hier erst mal gemeinsam Fußball und haben eine gute Zeit. Also ich glaube, diese Erwartungshaltung, die man da auf politischer Seite hat, die ist extrem hoch. Ich persönlich erlebe das aber nicht so, dass das gesellschaftlich gerade so gefühlt wird. Ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht, ob ihr da andere Eindrücke habt als ich, aber...
Das ist einfach so eine Erzählung, glaube ich, die man jetzt probiert, auch weil auch die Politik natürlich von diesem Turnier irgendwas abbekommen möchte. Das ist irgendwie das Paradoxe daran. Da ist was, was man möglicherweise viele Jahre lang gar nicht so gut findet. Also man hört ja sonst eher kritische Stimmen auch aus der Politik zu FIFA und Uefa. Und dann kommt das nach Deutschland und dann hat man selber Erwartungen dran, weil man eben selber auch davon profitieren möchte. Das ist jetzt in diesem Fall auch völlig unabhängig von irgendwelchen parteipolitischen Farben. Das würden, glaube ich, alle so machen. Das ist ja... Also ich glaube schon, dass das sehr schwierig wird mit diesem Turnier. Wir haben sicherlich auch 2006 keine Euphorie gehabt, aber wir haben eine andere gesellschaftliche Situation jetzt und einen Herbst vor uns, der in einigen Bundesländern sicherlich nicht mit Vorfreude erwartet wird, bei vielen. Und ich glaube, dass das sehr optimistisch ist, dass dieses Turnier da wirklich was bewegt. Also und ehrlicherweise, es gibt, glaube ich, auch eine wissenschaftliche Studie dazu, so mit dem ungefähr, ich kann es nicht mehr ganz genau zitieren, mit dem Titel Patrioten für vier Wochen. Was ist denn, wenn zwei Wochen danach und die deutsche Mannschaft ist vielleicht im Achtelfinale ausgeschehen, weil interessiert es vielleicht auch keinen mehr am Ende. Also es ist ja gar nicht gesagt, dass das funktionieren kann.
Ja, vor allem mein Eindruck ist auch unter dem, was man von der WM 2006 jetzt schon weiß. Es wird Gewinner geben von diesem Turnier, auch jetzt von der Europameisterschaft. Die Uefa ist jetzt schon eine Gewinnerin der Verband. Es ist ein Gewinner, so ist es korrekt. Der DFB wird vermutlich ein Gewinner sein und meine Güte hat der DFB Geld notig. Also das ist auch die Sportartikel-Hersteller. Also damals hat Adidas und Nike fantastische Umsätze gemacht. Das werden Gewinner sein und wie wir ja an der jüngsten Nike-Adidas-Diskussion gehört haben, ist es offenbar auch immer noch so, dass Adidas als ein streng deutsches Unternehmen verstanden wird. Und dann könnte das ja auch ein Gewinn sein, der Deutschland zugutekommt. Die Stadionbetreiber oder die Vereine dahinter sind Gewinner, die definitiv, da ist nämlich die Uefa dann durchaus spendabel. Also wenn man da mal liest, was da dann die Stadionmiete und dass jeder Platzwort pro Tag irgendwie 450 Euro bekommt und jede Putzhilfe bekommt 200 Euro pro Tag von der Uefa, also die verdienen definitiv auch sehr gut. Aber, und das ist eben genauso wahr, es gibt eben auch viele, die nicht profitieren und denen aber manchmal erzählt wird, ihr profitiert doch alle. Und ich glaube, da kommt das Frustpotenzial her. Und da kommen wir dann nämlich auch zu der letzten großen Frage, eigentlich wäre es denn anders möglich? Wäre denn ein Turnier, von dem alle profitieren, denkbar? Und ich möchte damit vielleicht mit einem Gedankenimpuls reingehen, Stella, wenn ich mir die Spielorte angucke und wenn ich mir gleichzeitig die gesellschaftlichen Themen angucke, dann geht es immer noch viel um Ost gegen West. Egal, ob diese Unterscheidung richtig oder falsch ist, aber es wird immer noch viel über Ostdeutschland und die Unterschiede zu Westdeutschland, die ja auch da sind, gesprochen. Und jetzt habe ich hier mit Leipzig wieder nur einen Spielort in Ostdeutschland. Wäre das nicht eigentlich das Allererste, was man anpacken musste? Wenn man sagt, das soll ein Turnier für alle sein, dann habe ich überhaupt nichts gegen NRW. Aber da können nicht vier Spielorte im Umkreis von gefühlt 20 Kilometern sein. Und der Osten bekommt Leipzig als einzigen Spieler. Also wäre das zum Beispiel so der erste Hebel, wo man sagen müsste, naja, also wenn wir ein Turnier wollen, bei dem alle profitieren, da könnte man schon mal ansetzen.
Definitiv. Ich finde generell, also egal, ob Ost, West oder welche Formen der Diskriminierung und Unterschiede es einfach gibt, dass die mehr mitgedacht werden müssten. Und dass wir irgendwie Sport nicht immer so als abgekapseltes Event sehen. Jetzt geht es hier aber nur um Fußball und wir wollen unsere Nationalmannschaft zugucken. Ich glaube, es gibt eben total viele Umstände, die dieses Turnier und die Stimmung darauf beeinflussen und so zu tun, als wären die nicht da, finde ich nicht sinnvoll in dem Moment. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, da könnt ihr mir wahrscheinlich weiterhelfen. Es ist wahrscheinlich auch die Frage, inwiefern gibt es in ostdeutschen Städten die Ressourcen, inwiefern ist es lohnenswert für die Städte in dem Moment, die dann ja eben auch bezahlen müssen, dieses Event auszurichten. Leipzig hatten erst Bundesligisten, das Stadion war da. Ich weiß nicht, wie es sich da in anderen Städten verhält, um ganz ehrlich und transparent zu sein, an dem Punkt. Deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie so die Frage, die man sich stellen muss, hat es vielleicht daran gelegen. Aber ich finde schon, dass gerade weil es ja eine politische Entscheidung ist, dieses Event nach Deutschland zu holen, finde ich das dann immer wieder absurd, dass diese Dinge so abgekapselt behandelt werden und es dann immer so getan wird, als sei die Europameisterschaft kein politisches Event.
Ich meine, die Argumentation, Matthias, wird natürlich sein, die großen Stadien, sie stehen nun mal in diesen Städten, deswegen konnten wir nicht anders.
Ja, das gehört natürlich zur ehrlichen Debatte auch dazu, wenn man sich mal die Karte der ostdeutschen Bundesländer anguckt. Also mir würden jetzt noch drei einfallen, die zumindest einigermaßen groß sind. Rostock, Magdeburg und Dresden, die liegen so ungefähr bei 30.000 Plätzen. Aber das reicht eben noch nicht für eine Europameisterschaft. Da hätte man dann deutlich mehr investieren müssen, ausbauen müssen, wo auch immer das möglich ist, vielleicht auch was Neues bauen. Dann haben wir noch eine ganz andere Debatte. Dann sind wir auch bei all ganz anderen Kosten. Das gehört zur Ehrlichkeit der Debatte ja auch dazu. Aber klar, vier Stadien NRW hätte man auch diverser verteilen können in Deutschland. Es gäbe ja auch in anderen Regionen noch Stadien, die die Größe haben. Aber es gibt ja auch Städte wie Kaiserslautern beispielsweise, die das möglicherweise auch gar nicht sich nochmal leisten wollten oder konnten mit einer Europameisterschaft jetzt. Also ja, das sind politische Fragen, die man im Vorfeld oder die man, wenn man irgendwann sich nochmal um ein großes Turnier bewerben sollte, was, glaube ich, in den Sternen steht, auf jeden Fall im Vorfeld mit bedenken sollte.
Und wäre es deiner Meinung nach dann möglich, dass es ein Turnier gäbe, von dem alle profitieren könnten?
Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt nein. Am Ende wirst du niemals mit allen etwas haben, wo alle von profitieren. Es hängt natürlich auch viel von den Rahmenbedingungen und dem Gastgeber ab. Wir haben bei jedem großen Turnier, kann man schon die Uhr nachstellen, die Debatte, wie wäre es eigentlich mit einem Turnier ohne FIFA oder ohne Uefa? Diese Gedankenspiele machen wir relativ regelmäßig. Auch das stößt an seine Grenzen. Wenn sich natürlich die großen Fußballverbände zusammentun würden und sagen würden, so jetzt machen wir es auf eigene Faust und liebe Uefa, wir spielen nicht mehr bei euch mit. Ohne England, ohne Frankreich, ohne Deutschland, ohne Holland macht eine Europameisterschaft jetzt auch nicht so wirklich viel Sinn. Aber das ist absolute Spekulation und dazu wird es nicht kommen, weil auch die Uefa es schafft. Wir sehen es ja auch gerade im Vereinsfußball beim Thema Super League, die Verbände schon sehr, sehr eng an sich zu binden und da auch Abhängigkeiten zu schaffen. Ich sehe es nicht ehrlich gesagt, dass das ohne Uefa oder FIFA geht.
Und mit ihnen geht es eben dann nur zu den Rahmenbedingungen, in die wir alle uns ja reingelesen haben. Danke nochmal für diese 190 Seiten. Also ich werde alles verlinken. Sowohl dein Stück im Deutschlandfunk, Matthias, eure Recherche, Stella, den Spiegelartikel, den ich erwähnt habe. Und dann könnt ihr Hörerinnen und Hörer gerne euch auch nochmal selbst einlesen. Ich bin sehr gespannt auf euer Feedback zu dieser Sendung. Denn so ein bisschen, es ist alles so, wie man es erwarten kann und trotzdem dann in den Details nochmal interessant. Sich das nochmal einfach vor Augen zu führen. Einmal bevor das Turnier startet, bevor wir dann zu Recht ja auch auf sportliche blicken. Das fand ich jetzt eben sehr schön. Und dann bin ich aber auch gespannt, wie wir in einem Jahr zurückblicken werden. Was das gebracht hat und ob die hohen Erwartungen, die werden ja sowieso nicht erfüllt werden können. Matthias hat ja schon ausgeführt, wie viel projiziert wird. Aber wie viele davon enttäuscht wurden und ob man vielleicht manches davon hätte vermeiden können. Also gerade diese Unterscheidung Ostdeutschland, Westdeutschland, die ist für Menschen, mit denen ich gesprochen habe, die eben in Rostock und woanders wohnen, für die ist das ein sehr großes Thema, dass die mal wieder nur zugucken im Grunde bei diesem Turnier. Und das lese ich ansonsten aber nirgendwo und fällt mir als im München Lebender natürlich auch nicht immer auf. Deswegen wollte ich es hier aber nochmal thematisieren. Also ich danke euch beiden sehr herzlich. Vielen Dank an Stella Hesch. Ich wünsche dir ganz wunderbare vier ruhige Wochen, in denen du alleine Bahn fahren kannst. Du kannst alleine im Park Bücher lesen. Ich empfehle da den 14. Juli abends. Da kannst du dir was richtig Schönes vornehmen. Da wird es nicht so viel Konkurrenz geben. Also ich bin sehr gespannt, wie dein Turnier sein wird.
Kann ja auch entschleunigend sein, in meinem Fall dann.
Aber wirklich.
Bist du dir sicher, dass man in Berlin alleine Bahn fahren kann? Oder habe ich jetzt einfach nur den Zynismus in der Stimme überhört?
Nee, du hast recht. Ich habe da von meinen Dorferfahrungen aus gedacht, wo es wirklich dann so war bei den großen Turnieren, da waren die Straßen leer gefegt. Aber das kannst du machen, Stella. Du kannst dann auf ansonsten viel befahrenen Plätzen, da bist du mal ein bisschen mehr für dich. Also vielen Dank, dass du hier mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk. Danke dir. Und ganz herzlichen Dank an Matthias Friebe. Wenn alles gut geht, dann hören wir uns vielleicht nochmal hier im Rasenfunk. Du wirst viel unterwegs sein. Ich hoffe ja, wir sehen uns dann auch, wenn das bei mir mit der Akkreditierung klappt. Ja, ich komme noch nicht rein. Aber ja, also Matthias, vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst. Und ihr könnt natürlich den Deutschlandfunk hören, aber auch natürlich die Podcasts vom Deutschlandfunk abonnieren. Sportgespräch und so weiter findet ihr alle auch in den Links. Oder da hört ihr dann auch Matthias. Danke dir für deine Zeit, Matthias. Mir ebenso. Und dann danke ich auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern. Alles hier ist von euch finanziert, auch diese Sendung hier. Deswegen herzlichen Dank dafür. Und in dieser Sendung möchte ich mich bedanken bei Lukas, bei Mike F., bei Halloween, Amsel, bei Jascha und bei Gospod. Sie alle sind auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclubgegangen und haben uns dort unterstützt. Geht auf verschiedene Wegen, informiert euch dort gerne. Und abonniert sehr gerne den Rasenfunk Nationalteams Feed, denn da werden alle sonstigen sportlichen Sendungen zur EM erscheinen. Bleibt gesund, bis bald hier wieder im Rasfunk.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.